around 500 classic cars from over a
hundred years of automobile history
including some of the rarest in the
world racing legend Stirling Moss is
starting here in the 1950s he won races
behind the wheel of a Mercedes Silver
Arrow at age 85 he's still putting the
pedal to the metal it's fun but you have
to be careful because it's it's so
valuable such a special car that having
fun normal is really messing around I
wouldn't miss around with it I share a
great respect sterling loss has spent
decades in the driver's seat he was
famous for driving a huge variety of
cars he's also a passionate collector of
vintage models when it comes to cars few
can match his knowledge or experience I
can understand why they would improve
with age you know because they're so
special and the techniques of making the
way they were made not used you get
different materials now it is difficult
to know how much a particular car is
worth
very difficult did you try to send it
then you then you know collectors now
have a new way of tracking down there
next purchases people here are checking
the website of the historic automobile
group since 2009 they'd been compiling
an index that documents the value of
vintage cars former investment banker D
Trish hot lava keeps track of prices
over the past 30 years that information
then goes into his Hoggy index the
helped index our main index the [ __ ] top
index grew by more than forty-five
percent in one year that was 2013-2014
it only grew by 15 point eight percent
what's on average the market is grown by
sixteen percent per year since 1980
that's more than any other employer and
ocean is gerstein maybe Allison
people who invest in classic cars get a
different kind of return from those who
speculate on stock markets it's about
the thrill as well as the Prophet as
Formula One driver Nico Rosberg can
attest what time am i using I really
like classic cars for example i just
bought a pagoda from 1970 another
thought is of course that it's an
investment for the future like always
very very langa tuku the market for
luxury vintage cars brings in about 5
billion euros a year worldwide Ferraris
for example have sold for up to 34
million euros and a vintage Bugatti
could now be worth twenty seven million
euros Pink Floyd Armand Nick Mason is
another star who's invested his money in
classic cars
I don't collect them I have a lot of
them I never intended to be a collector
I wanted to be a racing driver
goodwood also does a brisk trade in
racing cars from a bygone era two years
ago a Mercedes saw her arrow from 1955
fetch 23 million euros the subie saw
sawdust sports cars are the most
interesting element in the classic car
sector element they're always connected
to performance and competition the
moment performance on veteran-owned
vomiting and anyone who's ever driven a
car especially in competitive races
becomes part of its history and that can
triple in value and in Viet for iphone
Nico Rosberg thrilled the crowd by
performing a lap in his current formula
1 car
anyone who bought it now would be able
to sell it at a huge profit one day the
stim that it's true that it's going to
be very valuable in the future but the
problem is that when people buy cars
from the 60s and 70s they can jump in
turn on the engine and drive off it's
different with this car I don't know how
many people you even need to get it
going with all the electronics inside
electronic analysis other witness no
demand for classic cars continues to
rise the supply stays pretty much the
same so it's no surprise that every year
they become more and more valuable